there are lots of people these days
making demands against the universe uh
people like leah thomas for example
demanding to be seen as a woman in fact
to be a woman but he's not
um now this is uh this is just some
fortuitous timing i think because leah
thomas of course as you know the u-pen
swimmer who's a male competing against
the females stealing all their uh metals
and and um accolades and everything else
good morning america
has a little bit of a puff piece that
they they're airing this the first this
first time we've seen i think leah
thomas he he had the
the puff piece interview profile with
sports illustrated but his first time
we've seen him interviewed on camera
um and he's been interviewed by good
morning america so first i want to play
this
and i have a little bit of a rebuttal to
play as well but first let's listen to
good morning america and leah thomas
talk about well in fact what it says on
the screen is leah thomas breaks her
quote unquote
silence listen
thomas began hrt hormone replacement
therapy in may of her sophomore year
2019. the mental and emotional changes
actually happened very quickly i was
feeling a lot better mentally i was i
was less depressed and i lost muscle
mass and i became
a lot weaker and a lot a lot slower in
the water
after following ncaa guidelines of a
year of hormone therapy to change gender
categories thomas started her senior
year on the women's team but her success
in the water was met with outrage
leading up to the ncaa championships her
critics say she jumped in the rankings
between the men's and the women's team
there are some who look at the data
and suggest that you're enjoying a
competitive advantage what do you say to
that there's a lot of factors that go
into
a race and how
how well you do and the biggest change
for me is that i'm happy
and sophomore year
um where i had my best times competing
with the men
i was miserable and so having that
be lifted is
incredibly relieving and allows me to
put my all into
training into racing trans people
don't transition for athletics we
transition to be happy and authentic
and our true selves transitioning to get
an advantage is not something that ever
factors in to
our decisions you didn't
transition to win more medals no
that's actually my first time watching
that just now and uh i mean it's it's
exactly what you expect speaking of uh
offering no defense having no defense
this is always the theme with the left
there's no defense of anything they say
especially when it comes to gender and
uh so so he's given the opportunity
there to respond the critics say that
males have competitive advantages no
critics don't say that you know it says
that um uh science says that okay we're
very bluff's usually very fond of saying
that that science has declared certain
things well this is one thing that
science is
is uh 100
this is a a universal
immutable truth
right that there are biological
differences between males and females
we're also told by
the reporter there that what critics
critic critics say
that leah thomas jumped in the rankings
from male to female
what no that's not again that's not what
critics are critics might be saying that
but that's just a fact you can look at
the rankings
you could look at leah thomas
uh
against the males and he's down here and
then against the females and he's up
there that's just a fact
but given the opportunity
in a very friendly environment here as
we could clearly see given the
opportunity to respond to this
the critics say that you have an
advantage
what's his response does he give any
scientific answer does he no he just he
pivots away from that immediately
and says well
i'm happier
so
who gives a damn that's not number one
that's not the question the question is
do you have a biological advantage
i'm happy
okay you might as well respond by
telling me what you had for lunch this
afternoon makes no difference that's not
the question
but because they're
the answer obviously is yes of course i
have a biological advantage
but
that makes me happy
and so you should just have to deal with
it
now the other thing you notice in uh and
i haven't watched the full
interview
with leah thomas can't say that i really
plan on it but i have read other
interviews including that sports
illustrated one
and um the one thing you notice is that
leah thomas
never
says anything about
his teammates
it's always me me my i me me mine
i'm happy this makes me feel good
that's all he ever says
because the the the women the actual
women involved don't factor in they
don't matter he doesn't care he's a
raging narcissist
simply doesn't care to now does he have
does he actually have gender dysphoria
is he actually confused about
um about his uh about his biological sex
maybe
you know or or maybe not i mean it's
we can't really we can't know
we can't see inside someone's mind
um is this something he's doing just for
for an advantage purely and for
attention and all that seems quite
possible to me but i don't know it also
doesn't really
matter
um when it comes to this question of
whether it's fair and right and it makes
sense to have males competing against
women
but whether he actually has this
confusion or not one thing we know for
sure is that this that he is a again a
raging narcissist
doesn't care about anybody else
um but even if the other people
involved don't rank as far as he's
concerned
um in reality they do exist and they do
matter and it just so happens that in my
film what is a woman i don't know if you
heard mention it comes out tomorrow we
actually spoke to uh one of the
teammates of leah thomas
and
she
you know for
uh understandable reasons
didn't want her name and face out they
wanted wanted some anonymity but was
willing to speak to us and so i want to
play we're gonna play this is an
exclusive clip from what is a woman very
very short clip again you can see the
full film when it comes out tomorrow go
to what is women dot com and subscribe
but let's listen to
to what she has to say
about her experiences with leah thomas
on the team and in particular
did anyone did any of the women on the
team raise any concerns did they object
and if they did
what what response did they get from the
school let's listen
leah obviously helps us do better right
via swimming really fast leah's
performance helps the university of
pennsylvania swim team the feeling of
winning doesn't feel as good anymore
because it feels tainted there was a lot
of things you couldn't talk about that
were very concerning like a locker room
situation
if you even brought up concerns about it
you're transphobic if you even bring up
the fact that leah swimming might not be
fair you were immediately shut down this
being called a hateful person or
transphobic but there's never any
conversation the coaches don't
sit everyone down and acknowledge what
everyone's really upset about so pat
actually brought in people high up in
the athletic department to talk to us
they brought in someone from like the
lgbtq center they brought in someone
from the psychological services so you
you're upset about what's happening and
so you need psychological help yeah and
they told us in this meeting they said
look we understand there's an array of
emotions but leah's swimming is a
non-negotiable however we can help you
make that okay that's what we're here
for
now on the left they're very fond of the
term gaslighting and we hear it all the
time they're always accusing people oh
you're gaslighting me
and usually you get accused of
gaslighting if you just say something
that's plainly correct and obvious and
then you're accused of gaslighting
well this that what you just heard there
that's gaslighting what the what the
girls experienced on their team is
gaslighting
where if you have a problem if you're
uncomfortable
being around a man in your locker room
if you don't want to see a penis in a
locker room
or if you've done all this work to this
point in your swimming career and you
don't like the idea that now you're
being overshadowed and having this
opportunity stolen from you then you are
the one with the problem
you need to go get psychological
counseling
that's what she reveals there
they sat they sat the
the women down the actual women
brought in lgbt activists to shame them
for not wanting to see a naked penis in
the locker room
and then they were told that hey if you
don't like this then we'll send you then
you're the crazy one
you you could go talk to a counselor no
the uh the man
who's dressing like a woman
you know he's he doesn't have a
psychological problem you do
so if there's if there's one man saying
that he's a woman
and then you know
10 women
20 women
who
disagree
who's who's the one with the problem
it's it's the it's all the women doesn't
matter how many it is it could be a
million to one
and they're the ones with the problem
so she had more to say again you can go
to the uh to what is woman.com get
subscribed and that's just one small
piece of what we have in that film but
giving voice to uh that's one of the
things we're able to do in this movie
that i'm proud of that we're able to
give voice to
uh
people who've been actually silenced
and ignored
but whose voices
in fact do matter
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated